d4
all right so we have either a king's
indian or a greenfield
we have a grunfeld who i want to play
here there's so many things white can do
here
they're all tricky so let's go into the
main lines
takes bishop c4 and knight e2
the idea of knight e2 here is if the
knight's on f3 bishop g4 is annoying but
now i can meet it with f3 myself
castles c7
rook c1
here how does this go
i believe f4 is a move here
f4 looks a little too weakening
that's some challenges like involve a
rook or rook first first seven
spawn moves i could try something like
that
actually maybe i've got a bunch more
streams so maybe on one of those
a6 i'm actually tempted to play a4 here
i haven't really seen this against the
green font
what happens if i do a4 and just aim to
put the bishop on a2
yeah maybe on another stream i'll do
some kind of theme
or i have to play certain ways
this and this is just an instinct of
mine anytime black's trying to do
something like this i really want to
stop
it
that being said black's played this
greenfield pretty logically still has
latent pressure
and should be doing just fine
the same time it's tricky to find what
to do in a lot of these positions
so e6 now now that there's no bishop g4
now i'll go f4 a name for this play
and f5 is always an idea just going all
in on the king side the queen can come
around this way
yeah we're here preparing b5 this is
logical
this is all very logical from black
let me do let me do d5 now
b5 takes takes bishop a2
ah but black is c4
but taking this way this solves some of
the problems i had
i'm not
yeah i was a bit worried about this
bishop but now
so black has this 97 of course but now i
just go c4
yeah let's just reinforce it with c4
and i'm fine with allowing this trade
because i get a lot of pressure in my
pawn center
becomes very strong both captures
recaptures are actually interesting
so we're going
to bring the queen towards the king side
let's do
or do i reinforce e4
let's reinforce e4 i don't see anything
too direct here
tapes and now i take this way
taking this way gives good squares to
the rook and bishop and i didn't want to
allow that
so now knight comes up
is there a game of yours i should check
out
i mean well if you're asking me what
game makes me look good you should
definitely look at my game against
manueli
from 20 from 2010 it was my first win
against the grand master
or sorry from 2009
that was a very fun game
and now now i can secure these pawns
pretty well
long term if i get to play this and
these pawns are safe it's just hard for
black to do anything
yeah my game against him my first win
against a gm
and to this day my favorite
yep 2009
and this is kind of the danger of the
grindfeld you get this pressure on the
center
but if you can't make it amount to
something concrete
then the center just dominates the board
and now i have problem no black has
problems on d6
so i grab this
and nothing nothing doing with the
center just yet so i'll take this pawn
i want to trade off these bishops so he
goes here
i'm actually tempted to give up a pawn
just to trade off these bishops
yeah i'm going to do that
so black gets this pawn but the king is
very weak
i have to take otherwise bishop a4
trade these
and now just f5 this queenside pawn
would be dangerous but my kingside
attack
is very fast queen b2 is a good move but
i go to the f file
this is very dangerous now
so black goes rook f8 so i'll go f6
looking for these checkmates
queen e5 is another good move so i'll go
let's see dog queen e3 for doing a queen
h3
i'm gonna go queen
we're both tempting
actually i'm gonna hold off i'm gonna
target this pawn first and see how black
reacts
now i go queen e3
oh but c3 unfortunately
this threat is too strong
game male chess